l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de la
proposition de résolution tendant à
créer une commission denquête pour
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
face aux grandes pandémies à la lumière
de la crise sanitaire de lakovic 19 et
de sa gestion présenté par le président
du sénat j'indique que la commission des
lois a déclaré cette proposition de
résolution conforme aux dispositions de
l'article 6 de l'ordonance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires le
président de la commission me me le
confirme je vais mettre aux voix
l'article unique constituant l'ensemble
de la proposition de résolution
j'ai déjà des demandes d'explications de
vote donc je ne pose même pas la
question
puisqu'elles sont déjà arrivés la
présidence je rappelle que le cdh a fixé
explications de vote à 2 minutes 30
il y à un orateur par groupe la parole
est à madame la présidente eliane
assassi président du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes pour
2030 madame la présidente
ainsi monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je tiens tout d'abord à saluer
l'initiative du sénat et de son
président de créer au sein de notre
haute assemblée une commission d'
enquête sur les politiques publiques
menées durant la pandémie de kobe de 19
pour en tirer toutes les conclusions
pour l'avenir de notre pays
une telle commission d'enquêté est
indispensable pour comprendre les
défaillances de notre système de santé
et en particulier des missions des
agences régionales de santé mais aussi
du pilotage national et de la gestion
des stocks de médicaments et de
fournitures médicales notre objectif ne
doit pas être de recopier le travail de
nos collègues députés mais d'y apporter
un éclairage complémentaire avec le
prisme de nos élus locaux qui ont été en
première ligne durant la peau la
polémique nous espérons que cette
commission sénatoriale permettra de
mettre en lumière un certain nombre de
fragilité de notre système de santé dont
l'origine revient aux gouvernements
précédents comme actuelle
la pandémie a apporté un terrible
démenti aux politiques publiques qui ont
oeuvré avec obstination à
l'affaiblissement de notre système de
santé des infrastructures publiques de
soins elle a mis à mal notre
souveraineté sanitaires comme le révèle
dramatiquement les difficultés de notre
industrie pharmaceutique à éviter les
ruptures de stocks de médicaments et par
conséquent à démontrer l'erreur de ceux
qui ont pensé profitable de soumettre à
la logique du marché la production
française et européenne de matériel
médical enfin elle a démontré j'espère
ce que sur ce point la commission
denquête dont la résolution ouvre des
perspectives d'une réorganisation dans
le sens de notre système de santé
rappellera l'importance de couvrir les
dépenses de santé au niveau des besoins
réels des hôpitaux
je rappelle que 5 milliards d'euros ont
été supprimées du budget de la santé
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2020 dont 1
milliard au détriment de l'hôpital
public en 20 ans cent mille lits ont été
supprimés dont dix sept mille cinq cent
au cours des six dernières années
alors notre objectif n'est pas de faire
le bilan politique du gouvernement
les élections seront ce sont et seront
seules juges de l'action menée par
l'exécutif
même si les résultats des élections
municipales de dimanche semble nous en
donner un aperçu sans esprit partisan
cette commission d' enquête permettra de
faire la lumière sur les
dysfonctionnements et leurs origines
d'identifier les responsabilités de
mieux appréhender des moyens efficaces
de lutte contre la pandémie qui nous
frappe qui risque de perdurer et dont
malheureusement des spécialistes nous
assure qu'elle va se reproduire sur
merci merci valable la président la
parole est maintenant président bruno
retailleau pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président à mon tour je
voudrais vous remercier de cette
initiative que vous avez pris en votre
nom mais aussi au nom de l'ensemble des
présidents de groupe les commission
denquête elles sont et je parle sous le
contrôle du président bah elles sont
aussi ancien que le régime parlementaire
et c'est un droit constitutionnel qui
nous est donnée dont nous devons nous
saisir dans notre mission de contrôle
cet après midi je voudrais pas d'abord
me saisir de ce droit je voudrais plutôt
évoqué du devoir qui est le miroir de ce
droit je pense que la création de cette
commission denquête est un devoir pour
nous un devoir d'abord vis à vis des
français il y a eu plus de 30 mille
décès et les français ont droit de
savoir
la france est de tous les pays
occidentaux et peut-être du monde en
tête malheureusement pour la mortalité
quand vous prenez des tranches de 100
mille habitants les français en droit de
savoir
c'est un devoir vis-à-vis d'eux mais
c'est aussi un devoir et je m'exprime
à 48 heures du scrutin de dimanche
dernier où on a bien vu que la crise
démocratique avec eux la toute petite
participation à l'est grandissant je
pense que cette commission d' enquête
est aussi un devoir démocratique parce
que au coeur de la crise démocratique
mes chers collègues il y à la question
de l'impuissance publique et cette crise
a révélé une terrible impuissance
publique de la part de l'état étouffé
par une banque rassis la bureaucratie
c'est quand l'accessoire c'est à dire la
procédure sien l'objectif l'essentiel
l'intérêt général
quand on considère que la procédure est
plus importante que l'objectif atteint
même le président de la république
souvenez vous le 13 avril a reconnu qu'
il y avait eu des lourdeurs des lenteurs
des failles même lui et puis ce devoir
que nous devons à la démocratie loup
devons parce que la démocratie c'est
aussi une question de légitimité le
président de république
l'exécutif ont leur légitimité mais le
parlement a sa légitimité est le propre
de la démocratie c'est que nous sommes
devant non pas un bloc de légitimité
mais des légitimités qui peuvent parfois
être
côte à côte c'est paris c'est le rôle de
la séparation des pouvoirs que le sénat
notamment sous votre présidence
cher monsieur le président a su assumer
pour notre démocratie
et quand j'ai entendu l'exécutif dire
qu'il y aura une contre commission
denquête comment peut-on dans un régime
de la séparation séparation des pouvoirs
faire en sorte que l'exécutif un pouvoir
s'auto contrôler
je ne pense pas que ça corresponde à la
définition que nous nous faisons la
démocratie voilà monsieur le président
la raison pour laquelle je tenais au nom
de mon groupe à vous remercier pour
cette initiative que nous serons unanime
à voter merci monsieur le président la
parole et mathon président patrick
kanner pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain de la parole monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
sans surprise nous voterons votre
proposition de résolution 16 février mes
chers collègues olivier ferrand nommer
en pleine crise de lakovic 19 succédant
à agnès buzyn ex filtrer pour cause de
municipales dont elle dira plus tard
qu'il ne fallait pas les tenir et pour
le résultat que l'on connaît
27 février première réunion à matignon
autour du premier ministre pour les
chefs de partis les chefs de groupe
permettez moi l'expression je la résume
ray par cette phrase cela sera dur mais
tout est sous contrôle
nous sommes le 27 février 16 mars
discours de guerre ennemis armés champ
de bataille morts au combat tranché
première ligne 16 mar discours d'
emmanuel macron grandiloquence d'un
langage guerrier inadapté certes certes
nous avons dû affronter une très grave
crise sanitaire
certes lakovic 19 as tu es tu tueras des
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
le monde mais ce virus mes chers
collègues n'a pas de conscience n'a pas
de projet d'envahissement n'a pas
d'histoire et je l'espère n'a pas
d'avenir
les seuls alliés potentiels ce sont les
hommes et les femmes qui le font
diffuser auprès de la population à
monsieur prison oui nous avons été
frappés par cette grave crise d'une
violence inouïe
une crise qui n'est pas encore derrière
nous il faut donc comprendre
effectivement comme le disait le prudent
retailleau il faut comprendre ce que
nous venons de traverser qui n'est pas
fini dans son adresse aux français du 13
avril dernier
président de la république a eu un
moment de sincérité pour ne pas dire de
lucidité en parlant de failles
d'insuffisances dans la gestion de la
crise j'aimerais pas être ministre quand
le président vous dis cela le rôle du
sénat et de déceler ses failles ses
insuffisances pour les combler les
réparer et surtout les prévenir
donc nous félicitons que la haute
assemblée est pris cette décision
extrêmement utile notre décision qui
était quand même beaucoup plus fluide
qu'à l'assemblée nationale nous allons
encore une fois tenir notre rang comme
dans d'autres épisodes politiques
récents nous estimons que la mission de
contrôle est essentiel pour notre
démocratie
certes une deuxième vague réduire à
néant les efforts fournis jusqu'à
présent et viendrait heurter de plein
fouet un système de santé qui est déjà
très affaiblie par la première vague et
je vous invite à écouter ce que nous
disent les soignants qui sont dans la
rue de paris
aujourd'hui cela comptera pour demain ce
travail du sénat le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président prendra toute sa
part dans le travail qui sera le nôtre
collectif durant ces prochains mois
audit de l'état préparation de la france
de la gestion de la crise sanitaire
esquisse des perspectives pour la suite
autant d'étapes nécessaires auxquels nos
concitoyens ont un droit et un même un
devoir de savoir c'est cela qui animera
notre présence au sein de la commission
denquête merci monsieur le président la
parole est à notre collègue emmanuel
capus pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
la proposition de résolution que nous
examinons s'inscrit dans le cadre de
l'exercice par le sénat de ses missions
de contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
prévu par notre constitution
il ne s'agit ni d'un exercice de style
qui viendrait à mimer la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale ni mes
chers collègues d'un procès politique à
l'encontre de notre gouvernement
l'esprit à la fois critique et
constructif de cette commission denquête
nous permettra d'établir je l'espère un
bilan de l'action publique de ces
derniers mois qui ne ressemblait à aucun
autre mois
nous accorderons une attention toute
particulière à la cohérence et à la
clarté de la communication de crise à la
gestion des fausses informations dans un
contexte de grande incertitude et à
l'analyse de l'éthique des décisions
seront mises au clair les raisons du
manque de masquer les décisions
relatives aux durées de confinement et à
ses modalités ainsi que les conséquences
de l'épidémie sur les continuités de
soins en tant qu'orateur du groupe les
indépendants à l'origine de la mission
d'information sur les pénurie de vaccins
et de médicaments
j'accorderai une attention particulière
aux problèmes de dépendance de la france
à l'égard de la chine en matière de
produits de santé prioritaires dans le
prolongement du rapport de notre
collègue jean pierre decool qui avait
prédit ce danger dès le mois d'octobre
cette commission sera avant tout un
exercice pragmatique qui servira à
alimenter l'action future en matière de
santé publique
en accordant une large part au débat
contradictoire
elle viendra compléter et approfondir
utilement l'exercice réalisé par
l'assemblée nationale
la france a trop longtemps négligé sa
politique de prévention
cet exercice de rigueur et d'humilité
permettra à notre société d'avancer dans
le bon sens nous voterons donc vous
l'avez compris avec détermination la
proposition de résolution du président
larcher
si la parole est à notre collègue noël
ressent pour le groupe de la république
en marche vous avez la parole mesure
collègues
merci monsieur le président mes chers
dans ce contexte anxiogène permettez moi
tout d'abord de saluer les
professionnels mais aussi les citoyens
nombreux à s'être investie par
solidarité et responsabilité dans cette
crise que personne n'avait prévu
mes pensées vont vers ceux résidant
d'ehpad famille soignants qui ont vécu
des drames familiaux et des décès
brutaux dans des circonstances plus que
particulière la crise sanitaire actuelle
est inédite par son ampleur
elle a touché et elle tous le monde
entier et a percuté tous les pans de la
société
il est donc logique que les institutions
évalue les politiques publiques à
l'oeuvre mais également question la
gestion par les pouvoirs publics de
cette crise
l'exigence de transparence est légitime
pour revenir à ce qui a fonctionné ce
qui a dysfonctionné ce qui doit être
amélioré
c'est dans cet esprit que la mission
d'information à l'assemblée nationale
qui a débuté ses travaux en avril s'est
dotée des pouvoirs d'enquêté dès le 16
juin dernier
en parallèle le président de la
république a installé jeudi 25 juin
dernier la mission indépendante
nationale sur l'évaluation de la gestion
de la crise ducobu 19 et l'anticipation
des crises pandémiques
je souhaite appuyer sur ce point cette
mission n'empiétera pas sur les
prérogatives du parlement
il s'agit d'un travail complémentaire
des travaux des assemblées
multidisciplinaire menée par des experts
de 100 scientifiques économiques
administratifs et sociétal la mission
rendra un rapport en fin d'année et un
rapport d'étape est prévu à l'automne
au regard de l'ampleur de la crise il
est opportun que cette institution se
dote d'outils appropriés pour évaluer la
gestion de la crise et ainsi mieux
anticiper les crises futures
par ailleurs le procureur de paris rémy
health a ouvert lundi 8 juin une vaste
enquête préliminaire sur la gestion de
la crise en france
si nous avons entendu des propos sur
certains bancs qui semblait vouloir
ériger le parlement en procureur ce qui
de fait s'éloigne des missions premières
d'une commission denquête lors de
l'examen en commission des affaires
sociales
le président milon a su nous rassurer
sur ce point pour autant la situation ne
saurait être exploitées à des fins
politiciennes
nous voulons une analyse approfondie
lucide rigoureuse objectif totalement
transparente
une analyse à laquelle nous procéderons
avec humilité en ce qui nous concerne
mais sans céder à des penchants
politiciens mes chers collègues soyez
rassurés il n'y aura de notre part
aucune complaisance à la garde
al-agha à l'égard des choix faits par le
gouvernement avant et durant la crise
sanitaire
cependant les décisions prises devront
être évalués au regard des connaissances
et du consensus scientifique du moment
notre grippe
notre groupe est résolument favorable à
toute initiative visant à comprendre
enfin pour finir et à améliorer la
gestion des crises sanitaires afin
d'anticiper dans les meilleures
conditions
l'éventuel deuxième vague notre groupe
sera donc favorable à cette résolution
je vous remercie la parole est à votre
collègue jocelyne guide aise pour le
groupe de l'union centriste la parole
mes chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui la proposition de résolution
présentée par monsieur gérard larcher
président du sénat tendant à créer une
commission denquête pour l'évaluation
des politiques publiques face aux
grandes pandémies à la lumière de la
crise sanitaire
lakovic 19 et de sa gestion l'intitulé
de cette résolution engage la future
commission denquête dans un travail de
sagesse dans notre haute assemblée
c'est assurément faire preuve loin de
nous transformer en tribunal c'est un
travail d'auditions d'évaluation
d'analysé de préconisations qui guidera
sans nul doute les membres de cette
commission des sujets délicats devront
être soulevée avec la plus grande
prudence mais également avec la plus
grande détermination pour mettre à la
fois en lumière ce qui a bien fonctionné
relever les initiatives locales qui
pourrait être généralisé mais aussi nos
défaillances techniques et
organisationnels ou encore les
potentiels conflits d'intérêts ayant pu
procéder même indirectement à des prises
de décision qui n'aurait été ni
totalement libres ni totalement éclairé
monsieur olivier ferrand munissent de
solidarité de la santé le rappeler sa
génération a connu le chômage de masse
la transition écologique le sida et la
colite 10
f au moment du dépôt de ce texte est
depuis le 31 décembre dernier
cette crise avait emporté la vie de 433
milles 259 personnes à travers le monde
dont 29 1436 décès en france
la détermination de nos soignants et
leur engagement sans faille dans un
contexte relative ignorance sur le mât
le mal qu'ils devaient combattre aux
côtés des malades les a plongés dans de
nombreuses semaines de dévouement total
tout en les isolant de leurs proches
les applaudissements quotidien à 20h
constituer la reconnaissance des
français envers celles et ceux qui
travaillaient sans relâche le ségur de
la santé apportera des réponses pour
revaloriser leur profession aussi il est
du devoir des parlementaires de
constituer à l'assemblée nationale est
ici au sénat dès commission denquête
afin de tirer le bilan de cette crise
pour proposer ensuite les améliorations
est garanti pour une meilleure
efficacité de notre système pour lui
permettre d'être plus réactifs et
adaptable aux crises de sanitaires
majeurs et enfin le mettre en capacité
de prendre avec assurance des décisions
libre éclairé juste et les plus
efficiente possible
c'est pourquoi mes chers collègues les
membres du groupe union centriste
voteront unanimement en faveur de cette
résolution
je vous remercie merci leurs collègues
la parole est au président rck et pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues la panne est mis de côté 10 a
frappé de stupeur nos sociétés
développées
alors que nous pensions que la
technologie de lier la technologie et
lyrisme à lui suffisamment mis à
distance et les angoisses engendrés par
les grandes épidémies
nous avons cru nous ont cru à l'abri
sans doute parce que nous avons été
habitués aux progrès de la science s'ils
reposent toujours les limites de la
maladie et aux bienfaits de l'état
providence et de l'administration
protectis cette crise d'exceptionnel
indé pas non plus totalement
imprévisible bien sûr son ampleur a
rendu nécessaire la prise de décision
très complexe dans un temps extrêmement
bref nul ne contestera ici ladite de
difficultés d'agir dans de telles
circonstances y compris en créant
quelques jours aux régimes juridiques
haddock dérogatoire au droit commun
toutefois sur le talent et ça use à la
frontale admirable
personne soignante la crise a été le
révélateur de profonds
dysfonctionnements de notre système de
santé s'est limité au fil des
gouvernements successifs
c'est le cas par exemple de la lourdeur
du circuit administratif de la situation
des ehpad ou de la communication de
crise c'est aussi le cas de la gestion
des stocks de masques qui a conduit
l'état à restreindre pendant un an
l'usagé tandis que de nombreuses
collectivités territoriales sont engagés
dans un effort logistique considérable
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que notre
collègue nathalie delattre avait proposé
la création d'une commission d'enquêté
sur ce sujet ça reçu le soutien du
président larcher et bat pour être
inclus dans le champ d'investigation de
la présente commission denquête nous en
réjouissons ce qui m'importe surtout
c'est que ce travail d'analysé en
profondeur sont menées hors de toute
polémique partisane comme c'est inscrit
dans l'adn du sénat dans la seule
finalité de préparer notre pays aux
futures pandémies
car il y en aura d'autres
malheureusement c'est dans cet état
d'esprit d'analysé de responsabilité il
défense de l'intérêt général craint
groupe du rdse soutiendra évidemment
unanimement la création de cette
commission d'enquêté
merci monsieur le président nous en
avons terminé avec les explications de
vote
je vais maintenant mais passer au
scrutin il ya lieu par me levais je vais
mettre voir l'article unique constituant
l'ensemble de la proposition de
résolution
ceux qui sont favorables manifeste en
levant la main
unanimité je ne peux pas question qu il
ya l'unanimité constater sur cette
proposition de résolution qui est donc
adopté
[Applaudissements]